B Beasley was in Nashville on vacation
but she came to the scene in solidarity
she and her son survived a different
mass shooting in Highland Park Illinois
just last July
happening how are our children still
dying and why are we failing them
expectedly
musgren Hills
people here told us it's a close-knit
community which is known for being a
safe place I don't know how do you talk
to your three-year-old about why they
were in lockdown today Natalia Cooper's
children don't go to Covenant but she
was so emotional as she told us their
schools had been on lockdown just nearby
just happy to be reunited with them and
so sad for the families that were
affected it's heartbreaking
family's worst nightmare in Washington
President Biden responded to the
shooting by renewing his call for
Congress to pass an assault weapons ban
we have to do more to stop gun violence
it's ripping our communities apart